it was the craziest moment of my life i
sat there on the phone and I'll tell you
I'll tell you I'm good at patterns the
same way that when I was an influencer
on Twitter and YouTube in 2006 there was
no money right but now Logan Paul can
make 40 million a year that's what's
gonna happen
Netflix treated it like a movie the way
movies are open and theatrical they made
a movie they put on Netflix and then
they expect money on television and rap
door and all that then all the kids the
King batches that Logan saw them they
thought they could make movies like this
they made direct to iTunes and this and
those didn't work either
right same old [ __ ] it's just the same
reason that Tila Tequila and and Dane
Cook used MySpace got theirs but it's
not the same level of like what the
economics are now for somebody that
really wins instant fat Jewish makes a
lot more money than Tila Tequila
even though was the same game ten years
apart the best thing I could do for you
from a pay phone at standpoint is tell
you why not to settle into your I do it
and that's why I'm starting it better in
my career know get educated on how much
the world is your fame is the ultimate
arbitrage in our society my entire
career and I'm not joking it's
predicated on what I learned selling
baseball cards I'm not joking yeah this
entire company and all its success
literally points back to baseball how
much the amateur IOU it was the craziest
moment of my life i sat there on the
phone and you know how your brain can go
really fast sometimes you and I was an
interesting point in my life because my
face I invested in Facebook early on so
this was a realistic conversation and it
ran through my mind of my god I came to
this [ __ ] country I couldn't I barely
bought my first pack of 83 tops could
barely buy a pack
and I'm just I'm on a conversation right
now to buy the whole [ __ ] thing this
is the craziest [ __ ] ever Ryan two
seconds come here come here you are not
gonna believe who this man is
you're not gonna believe this Ryan Ryan
when we first met mark marks the real
story is building a huge [ __ ]
business Ryan's just stepping chances
Ryan when we first met what was the
common interest guess whose guess what
what his father and uncles founded can
you [ __ ] believe this huge the new
catalog thank you it was very
interesting because my parent awfully
good dude yeah
[Music]
I can feel anything
I can sell everything anything anytime
always forever vlog I promise I'll start
talking more about sales
it's interesting here's what I'd say
first you have to know what your finish
line is I would actually say knowing
what your finish line is is the most
important part like I really mean that
like when I think about business in
general but I so for example if your
goal is to sell this because you guys
are both in a point in your lives you're
still young we're like you want this to
be the first I don't know enough about
your business but this to be their nut
like holy [ __ ] dollars each off the tit
you know well then you have to know that
and then I would say everything has to
stem from that but I think the
difference is the [ __ ] execution but
I would hire somebody who's sold a brand
like I would pay something with the
current state of the union meaning okay
whoever just bought things so they're
out there just bought it they're not
gonna buy it
here's situation here's here's
here's an emerging thing here's these
two guys who broke off and got a billion
of funding and you literally [ __ ]
reverse-engineer them I think the best
piece of advice I could give you was my
opening line which is okay cool
the other thing I would tell you is how
big is your ambition to set like the one
thing you guys have to do for each other
is the most important part is tell the
truth to each other how much like what
would get you off the table yeah and you
should do it on the first day of January
every year or like Christmas or when you
do your under you if you're aligned on
that you could create incredible
business opportunity I want you so my
God tell him say um who's that that's my
13 year old daughter 13 my 13 year old
boy that's amazing
a bow Rama hey hey so 1330 I've been
telling you man like what I'm doing is -
I'll explain to you why that happened
real quick Ava right Ava Ava what's up
it's Gary B I'm hanging out with your
pops but I'm telling him that like we
should hang out one day so I can't wait
for that keep doing your thing thank you
for watching I hope you have a great
night see you soon it's real by the way
wait based on what I heard on the
Flannery kick I'll actually go here
first I never start with this cuz this
is super altruistic but what I am up to
right now and an iris will tell you
literally and this is so audacious like
I'm basically taking 13 15 17 18 year
old boys and basically winning the cool
game with them and I mean number one
above curry above like winning like
they're number one cuz entrepreneurship
has been put on such an extreme pedestal
kilee this hot rapper in Toronto who I'm
friends with I basically am in a crazy
place and one that you couldn't imagine
I stick with me 13:18 not what you see
when he has some indication too clearly
but here's where it gets really good I'm
basically convincing these children
these young people that kindness empathy
gratitude
work ethic not champagne knocking you'd
be mad at me
no champagne no girls no private jets 14
but but really on a very serious note my
ambition for my legacy has no question
taking a step forward because I
basically convinced myself and this is
maybe me selling myself but my God if I
can commence 7 to 14 million young men
that the new cool is the things that I'm
about these emotional intelligence
skills while still being an alpha
I could I could have I could have a very
real a very real impact on the world I
really mean that by the way like that's
fine but I believe it for him to say to
me at the last dinner we had we haven't
had any good news
he's like my daughter was like showing
me this thing about Gary Vee is it
Instagram okay YouTube you're not sure
you do she knows that I identify this on
camera she his always starting things
I'm always telling her how how to do
things I don't really have you think she
wants to do but have a do things right
we're where I play where you play and
we're in a place she Spencer pond and
she fell in love with your
that's right and and yeah I got from her
the other day where I get the bandage
was nothing that I would find
necessarily useful about you except
except how she connects to you yeah
which I found fascinating split out for
me I ended up with two interesting
talents one of a communication style
that can penetrate a noisy world and two
with a disproportionate understanding of
distribution of attention Muhammad Ali
is Muhammad Ali because he understood
where attention was like people don't
understand how legends are actually born
it's not just a quality of your content
it's understanding when the medium
changes MA literally literally this is
data Madonna Michael Jackson and Prince
were the most all-in on MTV so for me
it's like a spooky like I was always
talking by the way I'm almost talking
right now is the agent of the human than
the human eye I associate more with the
architect of what I'm doing I mean 15
months ago I'm like [ __ ] I'm gonna
I'm gonna get every 13th to thinking
other America in the world
that's basically what I said I literally
had a meeting today I was like I'm gonna
win India and literally in 15 months I
couldn't remember this in 22 months I'm
gonna be like
[ __ ] huge in India and like yours why
and what and out so it's super
interesting but I think one of the
things that is super dangerous is
allowing any emotion or ideology to
dictate in the face of very black and
white human behavior
I have never fought the system of the
human being even at my own peril and
that is made me very successful there's
a lot of things I don't like about the
human being but fighting it is a really
big mistake I think you have to be
thoughtful about where we are in the
lifecycle of the middleman becoming the
Internet to everything and how that
plays out
[Music]
you